hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu den
versprochenen video zur ozean explosion
am und zwar hab ich mir gedacht dass ich
dieses match race team ein bisschen hier
ein bisschen verstreut da hingelegt als
ich über alles was hingesetzt mit world
ging es nicht sonst hätte ich natürlich
als voll gemacht
ganz einfach weil das ein blog ist der
durch bei der durch eine modifikation
zugefügt wurde und der somit in wolltet
nicht vorhanden war oder irgendwie sowas
keine angedachte macht bernd ab dahinter
überall so ein paar sachen hingesetzt
ich habe jetzt kein ob die feine
installiert welches mit fortschritten
wie nicht hinbekommen habt ich habe
keine ahnung von twist erst bei mir ein
bisschen komisch auch mit robbie greift
uns alle habt ihr so eine kleine
redstone kombination aufgebaut und ich
sag jetzt einfach mal viel spaß das sind
ca 1000 base t oder 2000 oder so auf
jeden fall eine menge und die sache ist
einfach die ich denke dass das sehr sehr
haken wird dass das wahrscheinlich
abstürzen wird und dass da nichts
geschehen wird aber wir können einfach
mal beobachten und ich würde sagen ich
bin jetzt erstmal hier raus und dann
könnt ihr euch das er nun anschauen und
ich drücke jetzt mal diesen knopf und
wartet dann auf das ganze signalroter
kommt und pc wittlich explodierende
musik und an
okay das da unten links otto konnte
ja gar nicht so doll alter ich freue
mich gerade wie so ein kleines kind ich
springe einfach alles in der luft und
ich höre immer noch explosionen hat da
hinten explodiert bratwurst nee da auch
proa hätte ich ja noch mehr setzen
können aber ich war schon 20 minuten
amrum setzen
von diesen ganzen blöcken hier ist es
wohl dreimal nacht also ich weiss nicht
einmal acht sind aber mehr 2024 krass
also der user hat gar kein ende von da
habe ich das nicht bis zu ende gemacht
das war's doch nicht kommt nur noch die
ganzen frames hinterher so weiter dicht
zu nicht nur noch an dich auch noch hey
dahinter ob das auto nicht das ist echt
krass
ich merke ich merke schon wie es
teilweise echt heftig ruckelt es ruckelt
immens krass ich spiele gerade auf 211
ps
ihr seht dass wir mal den wasser
verläuft eher rechts an guckt also ich
kann mich grad fast gar nicht bewegen
fliegt einmal runter doha
ach so die explosion da hinten kommt
jetzt nach alter also ihr wollte dass er
mit ziemlich fette einstimmung dass ich
das mache und mein pc ist gerade so am
haken richtig krank losfliegt
mann ich kann nicht mehr doppel space
drücken dass er das annimmt
ich kann nur noch hüpfen okay das ist
jetzt spiel also ihr seht ihr meine pcs
der allerbeste dienst offenbart gibt
werde ich das ganz schnell wenn es mal
nicht mag diese knöpfe so nee nee nee
nee also mit der bewegung und so weiter
klappt es gerade nicht so toll
ich würde mich gerne einfach mal in die
ich kann mich einfach versuchen hoch zu
bauen
aber das geht okay okay okay ist das
krank und es ist wirklich explodiert
immer noch was alter zieht euch das mal
rein
ich habe drei apps wird sich wundern
wenn jeden moment nur ein spiel abgehakt
ich glaube es ist abgehakt hey okay gut
freunde das war's ich komm raus ich bin
mit der maus noch im spiel und hey
sollen dass wir zwar jetzt geht's
minecraft keine rückmeldung her sehr
schön java tm -plattform se binary
reagiert nicht ja das ist die pin wohl
wieder mal stroh abrechenbar okay
manchmal fast beendet wunderschön leute
ihr wolltet jetzt unbedingt haben und
was auch noch einige meinen ich hatte ja
vergessen die meteor tnt vorzustellen
wollte ich machen habe ich dann
allerdings gelassen als das bei 100
tischen abgepackt er beim tausender tnt
schon abgehakt ist deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht 105 100 500 oder 1000 jedenfalls
ist irgendwo abgekehrt auf mein spiel
bei dieser matri weil mein pc einfach
nicht dafür ausgelegt ist in sachen hier
zu konstruieren
von daher tut mir das leid tat sich das
nicht vorstellen konnte ich hoffe ihr
seid auch nun damit einverstanden dass
war das web station explosion und
ja wenn es euch gefallen hat durch die
gerne eine positive bewertung da lassen
das wird mich definitiv freuen und dann
für dich sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten video wir können wir auch einen
kommentare schreiben welche
modifikationen eventuell als nächstes
vorstellen soll
sollte dann allerdings schon eine etwas
coolere modifikation sein und nicht eine
modifikation jetzt einfach ein paar
kackt sachen hinzufügt achso übrigen
sich kein platz für die aufnahme starten
hierbei fraps ich bin nicht an minecraft
reingegangen und zwar fortschritte oder
has found the world all die miss matches
also da ist wohl ein bisschen was kaputt
gegangen schauen uns das mal ganz kurz
an
ich hatte gar nicht angenommen
ja gut die blöcke sind irgendwie weg hab
zwar nichts an den an dem haus verändert
oder so aber okay und hier der oceanis
auch wieder ganz normal weil es einfach
abgestürzt ist also na ja die von
schönen tag euch allen ich gehe das
jetzt mal alles so ein bisschen wieder
aufbauen mein pc